und weil herzlich willkommen wie heute
zu einem neuen video ritschel ich bin
nicht alleine meine damen und herren
sondern mit max laptop wir haben hier
jeder einen laptop am start mit google
übersetzer offen und wir werden das
jetzt abwechselnd die davon versuche uns
einen satz vorlesen beziehungsweise
nicht vorleser einsatz eintippen den der
google übersetzer vorlesen wird und wenn
der andere lacht bekommt diejenige
person die ihn zum lachen gebracht hat
einen punkt
wir fangen an
ich lasse das auf englisch aussprechen
müssen viel lustiger und ich darf
überhaupt keine regung zeigen also ich
gucke jetzt einfach so in die kamera ich
lass uns jetzt auch italienisch sprechen
[Musik]
ich verstanden
dafür bin ich muss dazu sagen mein satz
lasse ich nicht auf englisch oder
italienisch aussprechen so wie du es gut
gemacht sondern schlichtweg einfach auf
deutsch deswegen würde ich sagen jetzt
kommt der sandskulpturen die kamera und
praxis überzeugt von seinem satz gerade
also los geht's ich will dir einen hund
verkaufen bitte bitte bitte ich will
[Gelächter]
dass mein nächster satz die video auf
deutsch vor diesen also
ich hoffe du bist bereits losgehen
verkennen ich stinke nach [ __ ]
könnte eher sagen normal michael
punktuell bei den menschen denn jetzt
das komplette würde so viel speicher
sowie wirklich noch nichts ts ts ts ts
hahahahaha und kursräume mit diesem satz
werde ich dich kriegen hoffe ich
vielleicht nicht ich habe leider trennte
deswegen sage ich manchmal vl die
tastatur und deswegen sage ich mir vor
gericht oder vista wird das einfach nur
ja ich habe gedacht wir sagen jeder hat
noch einen einsatz besteht 22 leute das
ist unser humor ist einfach darauf
beschränkt aber was noch ist der andere
jetzt kommt mein letzter satz meine
damen und herren 30 das ist meine
einzige chance aufzuholen guckt jetzt
ganz in die kamera ohne hände vom
gesicht es geht los
noch ein wort zur fixen spaß das weiß
sogar der horrend und kaffee für kaka
ko-marke seine selbst ist davon nicht
jugendfrei ist er immer sc deutschland
150 sinke andere klubs sehr gut meine
damen und herren
damit will ich da sagen wir endlich an
dieser stelle auch das heutige video war
meine nicht lachen channel mit dem cool
aber selbst dann wenn es euch gefallen
aber das noch mal gerne 364 likes sogar
38 43 ein halbwegs dadurch würde ich
sagen max kanals definitiv nicht in der
beschreibung von links rudi otto glas
wasser ist ihr vom video das war es
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job aus checken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auch
die glocken klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]